it's gun week now the founding fathers
understood that only an armed people
could truly be a free people so this
week I invite you to join meeting Mud
Club resident gun Aficionado Mr Johnson
here as we tackle the subject of
firearms from every angle possible in
today's episode we have a little fun
okay a lot of fun with Ballistics and
see just how effective each round truly
is
all right so we've done five other
installments for this one's really more
for us this is fun yeah we got some
ballistics
uh you can hit one of those videos where
we dispel some of the common myths but
this does kind of help do that because a
lot of people don't really know uh what
calibers do to soft tissue to Bone so
this is the proper uh gelatin that would
be used in the F FBI ballistics it's
clear ballistics gel which is a
synthetic material the FBI uses organic
but organic's way harder to film with so
this simulates it very close it's okay I
stand corrected it's very close but none
of us have plotted a kidnap a sitting
Governor so I think the synthetic work
to the FBI and uh the standards for this
just so you know as far as defensive use
with the caliber is you're looking for a
specific penetration without over
penetration that number is so the FBI
standard which is kind of the industry
Standard 12 to 18 inches
um basically you want to get enough
penetration but not too much penetration
whatever it's 12 to 18 inches
we're children
none of us so uh Mike Mr Gunner go check
out his channel is going to be shooting
into this block or two blocks of
ballistics gel we are going to what
we're going to go 22.
380 a very common uh carry uh defensive
caliber and small farms then a nine
millimeter and we'll move on to uh some
rifle rounds and shotgun and we may
actually have maybe the Magnum round if
we if we get one of those we'll see if
it's laying around that'll be fun so all
right
watch uh watch Mike shoot and see what
happens in slow-mo in the gel
and you know we may maybe we could add
some sleep scape sounds let's do one of
those soothing sleep casts with
Ballistics
I think that works yeah all right
starting off with the 22 there yep
started out with 22 and we have a hollow
point round holy wait hold on a second
don't move it's a sign from God a
butterfly landed on his on his ears
right now that means that even God loves
him well that's good yeah yeah sounds
good so just try not to blow it away so
we have so 22 All Points uh out of a
pistol so it's going to perform
differently than it would out of a rifle
but let's see
foreign
[Music]
I thought it would yeah it's right here
is it the same block so these are 16
inch blocks
um and it basically went 16 inches on
the dot uh jeez I actually didn't expect
that that's kind of perfect if you were
gonna ask for a 22 to be a defensive
round right there's just not much like
it doesn't do much no it doesn't it's
ice picking through yeah all of your
pistol calibers are going to do that
okay so until you get under rifles
you're essentially just ice picking okay
so nice shows you what I know that's
interesting huh now we need to know what
round that is because that's that should
I shoot a lot of 22 in gel that's not
normal
was that a mini mag maybe I don't know
I'll have to check it out I think it was
oh was it okay well that makes sense
they're not a sponsor but they make good
stuff they do all right all right
perfect I want to see this no don't ruin
it we've so we're gonna shoot it again
well yeah no we have other ones but this
one I mean come on this one's still good
there's still a little damage right I
think so all right let's do it again
okay fine and then see what you mean it
feels nice too doesn't it
here let me grab the uh Walther PPK you
want to do the rifle 22 as well it's
just a good comparison good comparison
let's do that rifle 22. there you go is
it the same round I don't think it's the
same round let's play is it hold on let
me see what's in here uh
[Music]
no you wanna you wanna make it the same
round yeah might as well
it's a rotary mag are those magsful
that's interesting there we go there you
go all right
cool
you see the beads of sweat I mean it's
no butterfly but
all right up next we're going to be
shooting the exact same bullet but out
of a rifle length barrel so should
behave differently we'll find out
all right it stopped here yep
that's a little shorter than the other
one I wonder why yep so the reason it it
did that is the velocity is very
different so okay when you speed it up
bullets come apart fragment mushroom
whatever the case may be depending on
bullet design so that's why that one
penetrated less because it's spread out
more yeah so more surface moving through
well you can even see that it compressed
yep there it oh it almost looks like an
old an Old Musket round it's like a
perfect oh yeah and if you look here in
the entrance wound that one actually
either expanded or tumbled one of the
two the high speed footage should tell
us but just looking at that track it did
one of the two and sometimes I think
it's important people to note like there
there is a point depending on right the
grains like there's a point of
diminishing returns where if you fire it
too fast especially some of the like
sort of semi-fragmenting rounds where
they don't penetrate nearly as deeply
correct because it's all it's all about
bullet design so 357 Magnum is a good
example
most almost all 357 Magnum like
defensive loads are designed to perform
out of a three to five inch barrel so
when you put them in like a lever action
a lot of times they'll under penetrate
because they'll expand too much so
they're going to come out so quickly
right yeah correct how about we do this
let's just do flip let's turn it around
okay we need you guys to turn it around
so I don't mess it and I'll grab I'll
grab the 380 before we go on a nine
millimeter
stop it you're a married man Gerald this
is the Walther PPK okay so um this is
380. and it's actually a pretty good gun
to use probably could appreciate it I
think it's it's a longer Barrel than a
lot of the micro pocket carries so
you'll kind of get the right ballistics
out of it I guess maximizing it uh yeah
if you toss it single I mean you'll hit
it anyway but right now we have full
metal jacket so yes in 380 there is
somewhat of a debate between hollow
points and full metal jacket in terms of
how they perform yeah we'll leave that
to the comments it's one of those look
I'll say this because he's being very
diplomatic it is one of those rounds
that the 380. keep in mind we're talking
about the same diameter red as a nine
millimeter far less you're talking about
power like powder you can fit into it
right think of it as shortened and um if
it's a hollow point there's a lot of
data to suggest and there are some
exceptions but as a general rule unless
you have the right gun the right round
it can under penetrate if it expands and
so there are a lot of people who say
just use ball ammo the risk of it over
penetrating is again still pretty low
because it's not that powerful around so
a lot of people will tell you to use
standard ball ammo it's one of the
exceptions to the rule it is it's a
debate it's a debate it's a debate it's
a debate all right
[Music]
so that did over penetrate it did over
penetrate and it did tumble so you see
that type of wound pattern with Full
Metal Jacket that's 100 what it did yeah
so it went in tumbled
and then looks like it made a full
rotation wow I didn't know that it got
all that way in it yep so for this one
we'll get a tape measure here it's
actually a piece by the way yeah so talk
about 16 inch blocks probably went about
28 to 29 inches geez
so now how much of that you know we see
that obviously in the gelatin
um how much of a reflection is that
actually as far as would that have a
larger wound cavity in somebody probably
not is the answer so when you're talking
about pistol ballistics they don't
really
uh tear flesh like rifle rounds do yeah
reason for that is just velocity if you
think of your body your body is made of
water almost all yeah and so when you
get those rounds going fast generally
speaking over 2000 feet per second
that's when
[Music]
that's when Flash starts tearing uh
because it just can't get out of the way
fast enough gotcha so that's why rifle
wounds are just so much more devastating
than pistol wounds but I mean there
would be some tissue damage like that
but it wouldn't be like like what we're
gonna see with the rifles no okay what
about uh we talk about because we're
talking about like the hydrostatic shock
correct the wound cavity where think
about it it goes and we'll see in a slow
motion it goes well bass like this it
goes well these are technical terms you
need to turn yourself with but um it's
from Dune I don't know what happens
today where three guys like us who've
been out in 100 plus degree heat and
we're severely dehydrated yeah that'd be
a form of natural no no natural defense
probably worse damage yes okay okay we
have the Walther PDP and what I did was
I just so you guys can see I put in will
be like ball like a target round yeah
here underneath it we have a hollow
point so we can fire two in that way you
can see side by side the difference in
sort of uh you know the wound cavity and
I should just note before we fire the
hollow point that we're using is a
Winchester 115 grain white box it's
called so it's not the highest
performing round if you will so there's
newer stuff that's better but it should
replicate sorry Winchester but if you
know maybe you should just stop making
such poor performance yeah
bullets it's cheap though yeah it's like
the cheapest all points you can get so
yeah there you go High Point and the
Winchester 150.
[Music]
so that hollow point went in there only
11 inches so that's actually uh if you
look into the history of nine millimeter
that's one of the rounds that was used
in the Miami shootout in the 80s and
that's what caused the FBI to actually
switch away from nine millimeter was
under penetration which is exactly what
you see right here so only going in 11
inches
um in that instance it failed to hit a
guy's heart a criminal and he was able
to keep fighting so that's why they
switched it because of that under
performance but here obviously you can
see
over penetration as well so on that one
with the Full Metal Jacket yep we're
looking at 29 inches of penetration on
that round so probably more than what
you typically want and to be clear too
sometimes people get to this doesn't
mean that it will exactly penetrate
let's say uh 12 or 14 it's it's meant to
be a relevant metric to give you ideas
to what you're looking for with that
penetration to guarantee that it'll you
know Crush bone if it needs to make it
through clothing right that's something
people don't take into account correct
and it's also a consistent medium that's
why a lot of people use it because you
can compare round to round to round and
have a consistent outcome it's like a
barbell a barbell where you have the
exact like sure you can get stronger
using a kettlebell but it's hard to
measure whereas you know the exact
poundage it's kind of a good way to
measure progress so neither one of those
would be ideal no
well Miami ideal is here Ideo is 12 to
18 inches that's what people are always
important yeah just a little bit short
with that one now if you put clothing in
front of it
that could delay the opening of the
hollow point so it could make they can
penetrate more it just depends there's a
lot of variables gosh there's so much to
know
oh
time lapse burnt neck that doesn't
happen in 30 seconds but now we are
going to go on to the rifle and then I'm
looking forward to the shotgun Buckshot
bird shot this is two two three Yep this
is 55 grain so it's going to be similar
to m193 which is a military loading okay
for like 20 years in the military 30
years
um so 556 223 is a very velocity
dependent round so at this close up with
a 60 inch barrel it should still do
pretty well even though it's not fancy
and with uh something like this like
it's not nearly as relevant as with a
pistol whether it's a hollow point or it
still is but not the same degree correct
at this this is with a 16 inch barrel
not that big a difference all right
there's some there's some though there's
some there's some commenters like just
to be clear we're just saying not as
much right and there are people who know
what they're talking about that use
55 grain full metal jacket for defense
well you know we'll leave that for the
comments
all right let's see
[Music]
wow so what you see here uh probably is
more evident in the slow-mo that you
guys probably saw and what you see here
with the actual wound track itself but
as you can see it went in about probably
four inches and then started fragmenting
so what's happening there is the bullets
going so fast and it hits that soft
tissue the bullet itself is breaking
apart so
started to come apart right around three
to four inches I think SoMo would tell
us but I think it actually exited at the
bottom of the block so what you see
there with rifle rounds often
particularly Full Metal Jacket is that
they will tumble twist turn in the gel
and the same thing would happen in you
know a deer or your body and just to be
clear though we'll do that in the myths
video it doesn't mean that it bounces
around like a ping pong no no I just
sort of redirects a little bit correct
because the drag on the bullet as it
goes through changes yep that's the exit
hole right there Gerald has found it
let's shoot one more Yep to see if it
goes all the way through
um yeah see if we can get you can just
then ricocheted off of that the fragment
oh wow
all right so we had a very similar thing
happen so it turned consistent
performance if nothing else this one
actually went a little bit further down
on the Block this one's probably exited
around 13 inches
but same type of fragmentation in uh
ballistics terms we call it the neck
right there in the front and what
clear ballistics doesn't show all that
well is what the real temporary stretch
cavity would be if you're actually
shooting like ordinance grade gel or
tissue so you have your permanent cavity
which is what you see that's damaged
then your stretch cavity which this
doesn't do a good job of replicating but
I think the slow mo probably shows that
a little bit better than what we see
here with our naked eye but yeah I was
talking about correct this one exits the
block at 14 inches so still going still
going strong all right now let's grab
the shotgun and because that's one of
the myths that we'll be dispelling and
you can click on the link below where
some people say all you need is bird
shut
you don't want to over penetration you
just want bird shut isn't that right if
you if you don't want to win the gun yes
so uh 12 gauge uh we'll do bird shot and
then Buckshot into another block of gel
so you can see the penetration and why
it's a silly thing that only silly
people say
bird shot and Buckshot same block all
right let's do it
[Music]
all right am I the only one who thinks
that when you shoot that gun smells like
farts it does a little bit actually that
is all right so as you guys can see here
the bird shot the farthest pellet I can
see is eight inches of penetration
that's a nuisance and many of them
stopped at the three inch Mark are you
just trying to piss people off at that
point uh well yeah clothing on there
it's like pepper spray but it's spicier
and add PCP to the next right yeah
exactly exactly
[Music]
hunting with Harry Whittington when he
accidentally fired a shotgun not
realizing it was pointed at Whittington
the one we've heard in the news and then
you can see all the buck shot so did any
of the buckshots stop here yep there's
one stop there the rest went in here and
those are double hot buck shots so for
standard Buckshot that's the heaviest
load that people are going to use so
they make number one buck shot number
four buck shot those are smaller
projectiles there's more of them in in
the shotgun shell itself and they will
penetrate a little bit less so for
buckshot this is the heaviest
penetrating round that's typically used
so you can see here that we had a couple
of them stopped between the 15 and 19
inch mark and it looks like we had two
go out uh past that all the way out to
26 inches on that one so a little bit
more penetration it would be ideal
me personally if I'm getting a gunfight
I would rather have more penetration
than less if I had to air on the side of
one or the other and when you're talking
about the actual right sort of like um
the muzzle energy is that about the
equivalent to uh is it eight rounds of
nine millimeter clothes which is very
similar yeah yeah it's very similar
people rarely
take Buckshot to the chest and continue
doing whatever they were doing
um yeah it's true but that's not true
that's what they were doing was taking
Buckshot to the channel well then they
could still take bucks yes they could
even continue to do that but yeah I mean
you'll see a lot of uh security camera
footage all the time if people take High
Center chest hits with pistols and they
keep moving yeah you just don't see it
with Buckshot well we had someone just
this I don't think it's impossible yes
and this is one of those things that a
lot of people will tell you this and we
had someone who was an operator former
Special Forces say just trust me I know
what I'm talking about bird shot and
gingersnap said like wait a second I had
a friend who was shot with bird shot and
like he can still mostly see out of that
eye
like I'm not saying it's fun I know some
of the comments you go ahead and stand
in front of it and get shot with
Merchant I don't want to be shot with a
BB gun when you're talking about home
defense I mean it looks like a poppy
seed muffin yeah for sure I mean it's a
liability not saying it wouldn't work
but if you
if you're shooting someone there's a
reason you're shooting them right so you
want them to stop so selecting the right
round to do that is important there we
go ballistics gelatin and click on the
other links for uh for more of the
debugging companies oh shout out by the
way thank you to the uh the gun range
here yeah Texas defensive Shooting
Academy yep they let us come out they do
a lot of people come out here and we
didn't get to use a lot of the cool
stuff I mean it kind of looks like Mad
Max with all the tires but uh uh great
place uh took care of us and the heat
stroke is not their fault no they
actually have colors sweating is that a
problem uh I don't know but we probably
want to get some eat a banana odds are
good uh but while we're here notice the
pattern of the entrance it didn't just
spread out you actually had to aim it to
hit what we were shooting up yeah yes
that's true it didn't it didn't do this
no it wasn't like a stop sign moving
through the air no it was not ah yeah
this this would be obviously more so the
bird shot which would be even more
spread out correct and what about five
yards seven yards seven five seven yards
so yeah you still do need to aim with a
shotgun not as precisely right but if
you think it's going to be the size of
that uh you know that uh that communist
Target logo right there uh no you're
looking at about seven yards about the
maybe the circumference the opening of a
pint glass ish rule without my shotguns
if you're using traditional Buckshot
um the shotguns do have chokes that you
can change this with some do but rule of
thumb is one inch per yard in terms of
spread yeah I think that was just people
seeing it's like a show and tell it's
like a Magic School Bus but you know
Violet so subscribe comment click one of
the other one of the other videos
there's five we gotta go
if you like this video click like
consider subscribing or comment below
and of course consider tuning in to the
live show Monday through Friday 10 a.m
Eastern right here on this channel